en el último vídeo platicamos acerca del
punto de equilibrio y acerca de la curva
de la demanda y la curva de la oferta en
esta ocasión lo que quiero ver es cómo
se va a modificar este punto de
equilibrio si se llegase a modificar la
curva de la demanda y la curva de la
oferta por lo tanto imagínense que esta
es mi curva de la oferta y esta es mi
curva de la demanda de mis manzanas del
caso anterior y que creen en este
escenario se acaba de descubrir o se
acaba de inventar un nuevo tipo de
manzana que resiste a todas las
enfermedades es una manzana maravillosa
y no tiene problema de que se enferme o
de que salga mala por lo tanto qué es lo
que va a suceder a pues como existe esa
nueva manzana lo que va a suceder es que
van a ver muy pocas manzanas que se van
a enfermar y por lo tanto casi todas las
manzanas van a ser buenas para el
consumo humano lo que quiere decir que
la producción va a aumentar eso si lo
decimos otra manera quiere decir que la
curva de la oferta va a aumentar en
todos los puntos o dicho de otra manera
se va a recorrer hacia la derecha y todo
esto en cada uno de esos puntos por lo
tanto la gráfica se va a ver algo así y
la
enteras la que se va a recorrer a la
derecha y esto en un periodo de tiempo
determinado recuerden que estábamos
hablando de un periodo de tiempo
determinado que en el caso anterior eran
semanas y bueno entonces la gráfica se
mueve hacia la derecha que es lo que va
a suceder con el punto de equilibrio si
se dan cuenta este era el viejo punto de
equilibrio
este es el viejo y le voy a poner una
chica y se movió hasta acá al nuevo
punto de equilibrio entonces este es el
nuevo punto de equilibrio y lo voy a
denotar con una n pequeña y se dan
cuenta el precio bajo es decir el precio
del punto de equilibrio ha bajado este
es en el caso en el que se descubre una
nueva manzana más resistente y bueno tal
vez necesite la demostración formal y
matemática de esto sin embargo lo que
quiero es crearles un poco de intuición
y bueno vamos a ver el segundo escenario
en donde dice lo siguiente y bueno antes
de ver este escenario lo que quiero que
sepan es que está la gráfica original la
gráfica en donde comienza todo el
segundo escenario quiere decir lo
siguiente un estudio acaba de revelar
que las manzanas previenen el cáncer y
bueno pues nadie quiere cáncer por lo
tanto todos van a ir corriendo al
supermercado a comprar manzanas
más aún van a preferir las manzanas que
cualquier otra fruta
nadie quiere cáncer y entonces qué es lo
que va a pasar y entonces qué es lo que
va a pasar pues la demanda va a aumentar
y si la demanda aumenta entonces cómo se
va a ver la gráfica de la demanda bueno
lo que va a suceder es que la gráfica se
va a recorrer hacia la derecha este
punto se va a ir para camps este otro
para camps este otro para acá y por lo
tanto tenemos una nueva gráfica de la
demanda muy bien entonces aquí lo voy a
notar la demanda aumenta y bueno aquí
también lo voy a poner aquí se me había
olvidado ponerlo la oferta era la que
aumentaba y en este caso la demanda es
la que aumenta y qué es lo que pasa con
el punto de equilibrio bueno este es el
viejo punto de equilibrio ese es mi
nuevo punto de equilibrio y claramente
lo que sucedió fue que el precio aumentó
y también hay que fijarnos en la
cantidad en este primer escenario no lo
notamos pero también se dan cuenta la
cantidad aumenta la cantidad del punto
de equilibrio va a aumentar recuerden
que las manzanas nos echaban a perder
nunca por lo tanto la cantidad aumenta
en este segundo escenario qué es lo que
va a pasar pues tenemos que la cantidad
también aumenta entonces estás la
cantidad vieja esta es la cantidad nueva
la cantidad que va a resultar después de
cambiar el punto de equilibrio y por lo
tanto la cantidad de aumentar a las
personas van a empezar a consumir
manzanas porque nadie quiere cáncer pero
bueno prosigamos vamos en el tercer
escenario en el cual dicen que la
industria de sidra de pera lanza una
campaña de publicidad y bueno esto de
qué manera va a afectar a los
productores de manzana si aquí lo que
dice es que la industria de sidra de
pera va a ser una campaña de publicidad
eso no está diciendo en otras palabras
que la sidra de manzana va a bajar su
demanda entonces vamos a escribirlo aquí
la demanda aumenta no no no la demanda
aumenta para la pera para la cifra de
pena pero no para la ciudad de manzana
por lo tanto va a aumentar la demanda de
pera pero de manzanas va a disminuir por
lo tanto voy a escribirlo de nuevo lo
que va a pasar es que la sidra de
manzana va a disminuir en su demanda por
lo tanto en la demanda de la sidra de
manzana es la que va a disminuir eso
para abajo y si la demanda de la sidra
de manzana disminuye por lo tanto la
demanda de la manzana también va a
disminuir los productores van a querer
hacer cada vez menos manzana porque cada
vez va a haber menos sidra de manzana
entonces la demanda de la manzana
también disminuye y eso quiere decir en
otras palabras que la curva de la
demanda se va a recorrer hacia la
izquierda es decir esta curva es la
misma solamente que se va a mover hacia
la izquierda pues la demanda para cada
cantidad de manzanas va a disminuir y
eso quiere decir que la gráfica entera
se va a recorrer hacia la izquierda y
nos va a quedar algo así pero bueno la
cosa no acaba aquí porque los granjeros
nada tontos van a decir bueno si está de
moda la sidra de pera por lo tanto voy a
empezar a producir pera voy a dejar de
producir un poco manzanas para empezar a
producir pero igual y la pera está
subiendo de precio pero bueno al menos
lo que sabemos es que la demanda de pera
está aumentando por lo tanto lo que voy
a hacer en mi parcela es dividirla y voy
a dedicar una pequeña parte de la
producción de manzanas y una gran parte
de la producción de peras por lo tanto
lo que está pasando es que la curva de
la oferta
bien va a disminuir y ojo estoy hablando
de la curva de la oferta de la manzana
eso es muy importante vamos a hacer que
la oferta de la manzana también
disminuya y por lo tanto la gráfica se
va a recorrer también hacia la izquierda
me va a quedar algo así y entonces ahora
sí es hora de fijarnos en los puntos de
equilibrio y por lo tanto este era mi
antiguo punto de equilibrio y este va a
ser mi nuevo punto de equilibrio y
parece ser que no se vio muy afectado el
precio el precio parece ser el mismo sin
embargo lo que sí se nota claramente que
cambio fue la cantidad la cantidad
disminuyó 10 más el primer escenario
posible podría ser que el precio no
cambie el precio va a ser el mismo y la
cantidad disminuye y qué va a pasar en
un segundo escenario si yo exagero todo
voy a quitar otra vez todo y voy a
empezar desde cero y lo que quiero aquí
platicarles es qué es lo que pasa si la
oferta de manzanas disminuye bastante la
oferta de manzanas realmente disminuyó
demasiado porque voy a pensar que los
granjeros realmente cambiaron de rubro
por completo todos están empezando a
sembrar peras por lo tanto qué es lo que
va a pasar con el punto de equilibrio
vamos a ver
y lo que pasa es que en este caso además
de que la cantidad disminuye el precio
va a aumentar entonces el precio va a
aumentar y también desde cuenta que la
cantidad pues sigue disminuyendo
entonces en este caso el precio va a
aumentar y la cantidad va a disminuir y
bueno ya que lo tenemos escrito aquí
vamos a ver un tercer escenario el
tercer sub caso es que la gráfica de la
oferta esté muy pegada a la gráfica de
la oferta original es decir la curva de
la oferta no se haya modificado
demasiado no cambió mucho la oferta de
manzana por lo tanto voy a hacer otra
vez todo voy a quitar esto esto esto y
mi idea en esta ocasión es pensar que la
curva de la oferta va a estar muy pegada
a la curva de la oferta original si se
dan cuenta lo primero que se ve a golpe
de vista y quiero que se den cuenta es
que la cantidad sigue disminuyendo por
lo tanto lo que podemos concluir es que
en los tres casos la cantidad disminuye
pase lo que pase sin embargo en este
caso lo que quiero que vean es que el
precio disminuyó por lo tanto acabamos
de ver tres escenarios
en donde la cantidad disminuye y el
precio se mantenía igual el segundo en
donde la cantidad disminuye pero el
precio aumentaba y el tercero en donde
la cantidad disminuye pero el precio
disminuye también por lo tanto no
podemos asegurar nada con el precio pero
vámonos al cuarto problema que tenemos
aquí el cual dice lo siguiente los
recolectores de manzanas forman un
sindicato y demandan que su salario
aumente así que este es un asunto para
los productores pues repentinamente
todos los ingresos y los costos de
producción van a aumentar y por lo tanto
ahora el precio dado va a cambiar pero
los trabajadores están menos dispuestos
a producir manzanas lo que hace que
aumente el precio o dicho de otra manera
la oferta disminuye y por lo tanto la
gráfica de la oferta va a recordarse
hacia la izquierda me va a quedar una
gráfica parecida a ésta y ahora vamos a
fijarnos en el punto de equilibrio mi
punto de equilibrio original era este y
ahora cambio a este y qué es lo que pasa
lo primero que notamos es que la
cantidad va a disminuir entonces la
cantidad disminuye y qué pasa con el
precio bueno pues como ya lo habíamos
predicho el precio va a aumentar el
precio va a cambiar de menor
mayor y lo voy a escribir aquí la
cantidad disminuye el precio aumenta y
bueno recuerden que todo esto era en el
caso en el que la oferta disminuye así
que te invito y te animo y bueno siempre
intento hacer eso a que tú hagas sus
propios experimentos con el mercado de
las manzanas